we have Devin McCourty New England
Patriots safety now Pro Bowler two-time
Super Bowl champion Patriots captain
does a tremendous job on quick slants
which is also seen on CSN knowing what's
up my boy how you doing thanks for
taking some time good hey you know I was
just talking about the vantes perfect
suspension and and really there's
there's a couple of layers here dev that
I wanted to hit on first is how has
defense changed in the NFL even since
you came into the league and where a Pro
Bowl corner in terms of hitting strike
zones you have to concentrate on timing
all those different things how
drastically different is it the biggest
difference is on the amount of fines you
know I think the been trying to clean
the game up in I think they've tried to
identify and really you know let you
know exact strike zone and what is you
know acceptable what's not you know I
think they try to you know even help us
better understand that so you know the
difference is how much you get fined or
suspending and like a guy like perfectly
dealt with in the past and now you know
one Hitler preseason talk about five
game suspension no all I said I said the
big is different have you been fined in
the past death just want way back when
when I was a young guy my rookie year do
you mail a check did you send it in
pennies what did you do la they took it
it was up to lay off Iowa never sent it
so garnished your wages when you look at
where you guys have to concentrate on
you know taking care of yourselves
making sure you stay out of the league's
crosshairs it's the preseason different
from the regular season in terms of the
hits and strikes that you'll make Odell
Beckham was under you know took a hit a
couple weeks ago from I believe it was a
Cincinnati Bengals rookie you just play
football I mean I know for myself I'm
not out
you know thinking like let me play this
differ let me you know not hit a guy how
I would hit like I don't I don't think
about that once I'm out there playing
football you know I have one temple
you know game temple and I think you go
when you try to change that users when
you get hurt or you know someone else
gets hurt around you so you got it to me
you got always play the same in that
area what about trash talk do you get as
into it in the preseason let somebody
know that hey I don't talk that much all
right catch my breath the safety play in
general I made that statement about how
important safeties are in the changing
NFL do you agree with the notion that of
all the positions on defense and you're
a safety so you might have a little bit
of a rooting interest but do you believe
that safety is growing in importance
year by year because of the versatility
of a lot of guys who play the position
you know being able to cover you know
God's being able to play like
linebackers you know I think that's very
important especially when you look at
offenses with different skills that the
tight end position comes in many
different forms of what type of
tightening you're playing against it you
know they have safety you know that can
do you know a bunch of different roles
for your team's allows you to match
personnel it allows you to you know play
different defenses that you know it's
harder to play with you know a
linebacker or a coroner maybe um you
know Safety's better equipped so you
know hopefully I'm just raising the
price tag for safeties around the league
Patriots safety demo Corey joining us
speaking of price tags Matthew Stafford
signed a contract that is going to pay
him 27 million dollars a year five year
135 million dollar contract and when you
look at the way players are paid in the
NFL and quarterbacks are so far into a
different universe financially than the
rest of the players does it ever maybe
cause at least scrutiny as to the the
way that there are the haves and
have-nots as you guys look at the way
different position
are paid I think it serve I think to me
as players we should want you know the
price time for everything to keep going
up so you know people always argue about
how much a quarter of our sugar should
get paid but you know I think as players
we should want every guy to get paid
because in turn that just helps the
league it helps the players you know
continue to make more you know a bigger
piece of a part of the NFL makes overall
so you know I think obviously each guy's
differently how they feel about that so
we could you know I think it could rub
gods a certain way but Mastiff was a
really good player I mean we just
started a game plan for him last weekend
he's a tough guy to plan for he he does
a lot of different things on the field
fatherly was definitely well deserved a
hopefully we we keep talking about guys
with that hard cap see that's the hard
thing to with a hard cap there's
percentages though that a player takes
up so the more for one the less for
another yeah and we look towards the
collective bargaining agreement which
expires in a few years that's the
hardest thing is if you're going to make
sure that a veteran player a guy who
gets to 28 29 30 doesn't get put out to
pasture just as he's hitting his peak
earning years so that you can either a
pay the quarterback or be replace them
with a younger player it's kind of a
vicious circle is that one of the things
that you look at in terms of the labor
situation and say you know what this is
something we need to look at it's a
younger guy can always put out the older
guy you know in this league in exactly
what you said how it works just from the
thought of in a year or two the skill
level will be you know more comparable
and equal so you know a lot of teams
will be way more willing to do that and
pay an older guy whatever his number is
you know that he would make so it's
tough you know guys have to try to
that's what we always have honestly you
got to try to make your money when you
care
hey Jeff you know I you know what a
finely conditioned and highly tuned
athlete I am
I've told you in the past it's all
hydration it's all hydration in Tahiti
I'm surprised I'm surprised you know the
NBA someone's not paying you to be an
athlete rather than you know talk all
that so I'm shocked I think we both are
and it's getting difficult at this point
I mean I'm available for that
three-on-three thing that they're doing
to the big three so I can certainly do
that
have you gotten yourself you know in the
position where you subscribe a little
bit more as you're a guy who's getting
closer and closer to pushing 30 some of
the things that Tom Brady espouses with
the diet and the hydration and the
resistance bands definitely you know
hydration resistance and my diet hasn't
quite hit the Brady format so but not
definitely you have to you have to
started you know doing an even better
job of taking care of your body if you
still want to you know playing this game
with you know the younger guys in their
20s you know now that I'm over the hill
you got to start to think about that
well what you cheat food cookies is far
the biggest one chocolate chip cookies
yeah that kills me too with milk hey I
wanted to ask you two before we let you
go Julian Edelman obviously lost for the
season with the the ACL injury we have
the conversation so often offensively
about you know who the most important
player is and I look at how difficult it
is to cover Julian in short areas and on
third down what does the offense or it
scratch that
how difficult has it been over the years
to deal with Julian as a guy who gets
himself available in short area
understanding and how to get open and
honestly someone has you know time
playing defense and understanding of
defenses and you know what those trying
to do to take away different things
makes it either a better player and you
talk about his toughness and all of that
you put that along with it you know he's
a tough guy I think to defend but also
oh god I get to everyone else going it
makes the big play and keep
so definitely tough guy you know try to
replace I thought that might have been
one of the biggest aspects of him going
out had nothing to do with on the field
but it has to deal with that intensity
and the ability to bring people with him
with his attitude and personality is
that overstated by me or is that a fact
but I think if you know him a little bit
that that little part won't stop yeah
they'll probably have to make sure he
doesn't try to run on the field at some
point so I know he's a team guy he'll
stick around here he'll be around here
motivated and running it now all right
Devin McCourty New England Patriots
safety I gotta say thanks so much for
taking the time and we will see you
later in the week Patriots wrap up their
preseason with the Giants on Thursday
they have their opener next week against
Kansas City thanks so much death no
problem all right kick the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience